بدأ هذا
السباق الذي بدأ
عندما
نعم ، هذا ليس عدلاً ، أعتقد أن آخر
لعبة فيديو لعبتها بأي درجة من
الحماسة كانت لعبة باك مان التي كانت منذ سنوات عديدة
بالكاد التقطت وحدة تحكم لكن
فيل سبنسر خبير في ألعاب الفيديو
أوه  نعم ، هذا ليس عدلاً ،
هذا ليس عدلاً على الإطلاق ، كم
مرة لعبت هذا ، لقد عمل
في Microsoft منذ أن بدأت الشركة
الألعاب منذ 20 عامًا
في الوقت الذي كان فيه الناس متشككين في
أن xbox يمكن أن ينافس في صناعة تهيمن
عليها سوني ونينتندو
الآن مع  ألعاب مثل halo the console
تجلب مليارات الدولارات كل عام
لمايكروسوفت ثلاثة مليارات شخص يلعبون
ألعاب الفيديو على هذا الكوكب معظم هؤلاء
الناس يلعبون على الأجهزة
التي يمتلكونها بالفعل والتي قد يستخدمونها في أجهزة
أخرى.
نحن نضع اللاعب في المركز ونسمح
لأي شخص بلعب جميع الألعاب
المتصلة بكل المجتمع الذي يريد
الاتصال به بغض النظر عن
الجهاز الذي  نريد أن نلعب على أننا
نستخدم قوة السحابة لتقديم
ألعاب xbox التي يمكن تشغيلها على وحدات التحكم ولكن أيضًا
تعمل على السحابة وتأتي إلى اللاعبين في
أي مكان وهذا أعتقد بالنسبة لنا أن
رؤيتنا طويلة المدى هي السماح لأي شخص
باللعب  عندما يلعب الجميع ، نفوز جميعًا ،
هذا أنت بخير ، أنا على
ذيلك ، حسنًا ، لا نعود إلى الوراء ، دعنا
ندفع جيدًا ، أنا أؤمن بك أنك
ستلحق
بهذا ما يسمى طقوس الإذلال ، كم من
الوقت يستغرق إنشاء  هذه الأشياء
الكبيرة من ألعاب aaa ، التي تبلغ مدتها ثلاث سنوات ،
تطول أحيانًا
مئات الأشخاص الذين يعملون على
ميزانياتها
غالبًا ما تزيد عن 100 مليون دولار ،
أعني أنها بحجم إنتاج هوليوود
ومن وجهة نظر
الناس يمكن أن تكون أكبر لأن لديك
هذا  التقاطع الفريد بين
تصميم الألعاب الفنية التقنية يجتمع معًا
والمشاهد إذا فكرت في الأمر
في عدسة مثل الفيديو أو شيء ما
كوكالة وما يحدث على الشاشة حتى
لا نتمكن من كتابة كل شيء فعل xbox
m  ake microsoft رائع قليلاً
وهذا صعب في
عدسة عملائنا وسأقول من
وجهة نظر الفريق أعتقد أن الفريق
داخل xbox الذي يعمل داخل
Microsoft لديه صوت
فريد ومنظور فريد من الداخل
الشركة
هي
لكني أفكر في ريدموند آه مشاهدة
الحرم الجامعي وأفكر في كل الأشخاص على
النوافذ
وجميع الأشياء الأخرى التي أفكر بها في فريق إكس بوكس ، يج
أن تكون مثل الأطفال ال
ائعين في متجر الحلوى ، إ
ه أمر ممتع حقًا  مكان
للعمل وأنا فخور جدًا بالفريق ، إنها
الذكرى السنوية العشرين لتأسيس xbox ، ومن
الجنون التفكير في ذلك ، لكن نعم ، إذا استطعنا
تقديم القليل من الروعة إلى
Microsoft ، فلا أعتقد أن هذا أمر سيئ ،
نذهب  هنا نذهب إلى
هنا نذهب نحن نسرع الآن آه في جم
ع أنحاء الصراخ الآن في
ركة معروفة ببرنامج مكان العمل xbox
جلب رس
مات عالية الجودة وقليلًا من المجد أيضًا ري
شارد سي إن نيويورك